il y a le boxeur mais aussi l'animateur
deux facettes qui constitue a dit la
môme a dit l'athlète vous le connaissez
sans doute champion d'europe des poids
super-moyens ceinture que l'élan
courtois a conservé en battant ans
christopher est brassée à l'issue des 12
rounds
c'était à domicile lors du mail et 24 ou
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et encore
merci pour ceux qui me soutiennent une
ceinture européenne conquise pour la
première fois en 2015 face à l'espanyol
mariano hilario adila à mohammadia alors
34 ans succès obtenu sur le tard certes
mais le boxeur vise toujours plus haut
ce qui a fait la peut-être la différence
sur ce combat c'était peut-être la
détermination
voilà je sais pourquoi j'y suis allé je
voulais cette ceinture c'est un objectif
que je voulais atteindre de la
détermination il en a fallu aux sportifs
un an plus tard nous sommes en 2016
adila mohammadi remet en jeu son titre
face à l'anglais kaloum smith à
liverpool
un combat qui tourne mal dès le premier
round libinois tente sa chance mais vite
dépassé par son adversaire et larbitre
contraint d'arrêter le match
après cette défaite on dit alors le
boxeur fini c'est mal le connaître
adila se remet vite en selle avec l'aide
de la team farrugia et du promoteur
malamine koné alors ma carrière n'est
pas terminée
il faut le savoir n'est pas terminé ma
carrière je suis pas un rêveur voilà
rêver c'est quand on dort nord ont fait
pas grand chose donc moi je suis
vraiment plus qu'elle tient qui a qui a
des objectifs
voilà et mon but c'est de les atteindre
au printemps dernier le compétiteur au
conquiert déjà sa ceinture européenne
moins d'un an après l'avoir perdue et
conserve donc son titre en novembre face
à christopher rebrassé à 37 ans a dit la
môme a dit se laisse encore du temps
pour être challenger d'une ceinture
mondiale
en attendant quand il n'est pas à
l'entraînement ou sur les rings a dit
labeaume a dit consacrent du temps à son
autre vie celle d'agents de la ville
d'elancourt un travail auprès des
enfants de l'école
willy brandt comme ce jour là avec des
activités organisées au complexe sportif
de l'europe
hélas de la boxe semble se muer
parfaitement dans la peau d'animateurs
ses animateurs il travaille bien et nous
fait rigoler les gens tirent ses débuts
moi je pensais que c'était un simple
animateur et comme mes pas m'ont dit
quand il est passé à la télé bah ça m'a
surpris un grand boxeur et il est très
gentil directeur de centre de loisirs à
son arrivée et l'encours a dit là est re
devenu ensuite animateurs avec des
échéances sportives de plus en plus
importante
il doit composer avec un emploi du temps
très chargé mais effectue tout de même
un service de 35 heures par semaine pour
la mairie yvelinoise ceci une coupure
une coupure par rapport à à ce que je
peux faire le soir j'ai notre vie aussi
bon set cette petite différence le
boxeur finalement qui n'est pas si brut
que ça vu que finalement il est il et il
est avec les enfants aussi un rapport
humain qui eux qui fait que bah ça me
plait quoi a dit la moto m'a dit va
rentrer très prochainement dans une
nouvelle phase de préparation travailler
dur pour atteindre son prochain objectif
monter sur le toit du monde